yeah
when it comes to the horror genre the
war gruesome the animatronic character
the better
meet crazy Kristen she starts out as a
hunk of clay her creator sculpts her
form on a vertical table once he
finishes her shape he switches two finer
tools to craft her gory features
he uses water and a sponge to give her
skin realistic texture
once the clay is hardened they'll a
crazy Kristen on her back and drown her
in gypsum plaster
in an hour or so the plaster sets and
they remove the sculpture creating a
mold from which they'll produce multiple
crazy Christians
the mold is quite heavy so for easier
handling they sever the body into then
they'll fill each mold cavity with
liquid latex rubber a three millimeter
skin soon hardens against the mold
cavity wall they suction out the
remaining liquid latex
meanwhile they weld together a steel
skeleton a great for her ribcage a strip
for her spine chains for her arm bones
ball bearings for her joints and steel
reinforced rubber for her neck
so far crazy Kristen has skin and bones
now she needs flesh
they fill each mold cavity with
expanding polyurethane foam to control
the expansion they cover the top with a
plastic sheet and guide the foam with
our hands
the lower body doesn't require an inner
support structure because it's a mobile
just steel chains in the legs to hold
them in place
once the foam hardens it's safe to
extract crazy Kristen's body from the
molds
they trim off excess latex along the
perimeter then sit her upper body on a
large swiveling ball bearing mounted on
a vertical metal base they insert a pair
of rods through holes in the base each
rod is bolted to a plate sitting on
those ball bearing joints in her
skeleton the other end gets welded to
the base these cylinders are pneumatic
meaning air pressure opens and closes
them making crazy Kristen thrash about
it's all controlled by this digital
device they mount on a guitar amplifier
it sends electric pulses that control
the pneumatic cylinders an actress
records the accompanying shrieks and
moans they transfer the soundtrack to
the digital control box
the box triggers the sound effects along
with the movement
it's time to apply crazy Kristin's
makeup
for her skin colors they use a
half-and-half mixture of house paint and
liquid latex rubber for her eyeballs
they use off white opaque ink
then they airbrush the iris
and paint in the pupil with a stick end
of a small brush
a few veins with the red pen airbrushed
ink on her mouth guard and finally clear
epoxy over her eyeballs to make them
glassy
they top her off with a wig mount her
lower body to the base then complete her
look with a straitjacket because crazy
Kristin's home is the insane asylum
you